alors on m'a dit que le sujet c'était la
nourriture c'est ça les boissons
alcoolisées c'est bon ça compte dedans
ok je vais vous parler du pastis le
pastis c'est une boisson c'est une façon
assez bizarre j'imagine que la plupart
d'entre vous en ont déjà
si ce n'est but au moins vu et le pastis
quand il est pur il sort de la bouteille
c'est un liquide qui est transparent
alors il a une couleur oui mais il est
transparent voit parfaitement on voit
parfaitement à travers et alors si je
m'amuse à ajouter de l'eau dans mon
verre il se passe un truc tout à fait
étonnant c'est que le pastis devient
opaque et bien il prend un espèce de
l'aspect un peu l'étau comme ça et ça
c'est assez bizarre parce que a priori
on le pastis pure et transparent ok on
rajoute de l'eau qui est un liquide
transparent
on s'attendrait à obtenir un truc et
transparent est en fait le résultat est
pas transparent le résultat n'est pas
transparent alors comment ça se fait
pour comprendre en fait il faut
s'intéresser à ce qu'il ya dans le
pastis le pastis plus en fait c'est à
peu près 50 % d'alcool
et puis à peu près 50 % d'eau
évidemment il n'y a pas que ça dans le
pastis sinon ça serait pas du pastis ça
serait de la vodka
parce que vous rigolez mais c'est ça a
été scientifiquement étudié pour les
gens qui aiment la vodka la vodka du
point de vue chimique c'est vraiment
juste de l'eau et de l'éthanol n'y a
absolument rien d'autre que dans le
pastis et passe à un an le pastis il ya
d'autres trucs et ya notamment un
composé qu'on appelle la méthode qui est
en fait une huile essentielle extraites
de l'anis ou du fenouil et qui donne aux
basses tisse son bon goût anisé qu'on
retrouve d'ailleurs chez ses petits
cousins du bassin méditerranéen caluso
en grèce leurs acquis en turquie là sont
debout cas en italie et ce qui est
important pour nous c'est que en fait la
méthode vous ai dit c'est une huile
essentielle c'est
ces deux villes est une chose que vous
avez certainement c'est que l'eau et
l'huile s'aiment pas beaucoup
si vous prenez si vous prenez de l'eau
et vous essayez de la mélanger à l'huile
je sais pas si c'est quelque chose que
vous êtes déjà mes affaires mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe elle se sépare
l'huile flotte au dessus alors la raison
pour laquelle lui il flotte au dessus
c'est c'est qu'elle est plus légère mais
c'est pas que ça fondamentalement c'est
aussi que l'eau et l'huile chimiquement
c'est vraiment deux substances qu on ne
peut pas mélanger et donc en fait dans
ma bouteille de pastis j'ai ce mélange
oeufs avec de l'eau de l'huile et et de
l'alcool et l'huile et l'eau en fait ne
s'aiment pas vraiment à côté de ça l'eau
et l'alcool n'y a pas de problème donc
si vous prenez les bouteilles de vodka
l'alcool flotte pas au dessus de l'eau
important l'alcool est plus léger que
l'eau mais ils se mélangent parfaitement
ya passé il n'y a pas ce phénomène qu'on
voit là dans le vert dont chloé l'alcool
pas de problème et puis l'huile et
l'alcool n'y a pas de problème non plus
en fait dans ma bouteille de pastis
purger un ménage à trois avec de l'eau
de l'huile et de l'alcool et l'eau et
l'huile qu'ils aiment pas beaucoup
en fait ça se passe bien parce que comme
il ya 50 % d'alcool en fait l'huile elle
se retrouve dans un mélange 50/50 aux
alcools et ça lui va bien dans toutes
les molécules du ils sont parfaitement
dispersés dans ma bouteille qu'est ce
qui se passe quand j'allonge bon pastis
avec de l'eau je suis plus à 50 50 ou
alcool je suis plutôt à 80 voire 90 10
kw à 90% d'eau et 10 % d'alcool et salle
anatole de l'huile essentielle ça lui va
pas du tout et donc qu'est ce qu'elle
fait elle veut absolument se séparer est
le meilleur moyen qu'elle ait trouvé
pour se séparer c'est de se mettre en
petites boules en petites gouttelettes
donc il ya des petites gouttelettes
d'huile qui apparaissent parce que le
toutes les molécules d'huile se
regroupent cd coûte lettres qui sont
très petites halfon à peu près quelques
microns quelques millièmes de millimètre
alors maintenant pourquoi ça provoque ce
phénomène là en fait il faut comprendre
que ce qui se passe quand la lumière
vient frapper ces petites gouttelettes
d'huile qui font quelques microns vous
avez peut-être que la lumière c'est une
onde une onde électromagnétique qu'à une
certaine longueur d'onde c'est là
l'écart entre les deux vagues
de longues électromagnétiques cette
longueur d'onde c'est c'est moins d'un
micron ces quelques centaines de
nanomètres et quand londe arrive sur
cette gouttelettes d'huile qui fait à
peu près la même taille quelques
quelques microns maximum en fait il se
passe un phénomène qu'on appelle la
diffusion qui fait que la lumière est
renvoyé dans toutes les directions que
la lumière au lieu de passer à travers
le verre à cause de toutes ces
gouttelettes d'huile qui sont dispersés
partout subi ce phénomène que de
diffusion et se retrouve envoyés dans
toutes les directions et c'est pour ça
que mon pastis allongé est trouble en
fait semaine de ce phénomène de
diffusion il est assez connu on le
retrouve dans tout un tas de situations
c'est par exemple lui qui causent la
couleur du lait est ce que vous savez ce
qu'il ya dans le lait général quand on
demande sa la plupart des gens disent
oui à du lactose il ya des grès des
protéines
en fait tu le laisses et 90% de l'eau le
lait fondamentalement c'est de l'eau
avec des trucs dedans et ses trucs c'est
grèce ces protéines qui sont assemblés
en petit goût tout petit en petites
structures comme ça provoque dans l'est
exactement le même phénomène que ce qui
se passe dans le pastis donc la raison
pour laquelle le lait blanc et la même
raison pour laquelle le pastis allongée
et opaque
il ya un autre phénomène on retrouve ça
c'est dans les nuages alors là cette
fois c'est des gouttelettes dons qui
sont dans l'air donc servant des
gouttelettes d'eau liquide qui provoque
le même phénomène de diffusion de la
lumière et qui font que les nuages nous
apparaissent blanc alors maintenant on
va faire un petit petite variante de
l'expérience on va rajouter du liquide
vaisselle du liquide vaisselle dans mon
verre de pastis allongée je trouve un
peu et là qu'est ce qui se passe
il redevient transparent
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pour
comprendre ce qui s'est passé il faut se
poser la question c'est quoi du liquide
vaisselle et à quoi ça sert la raison
pour laquelle est ce que vous savez
pourquoi on utilise du savon par exemple
en fait laver les mains si jamais si
jamais jamais je m'amuse à vous enduire
les mains d'huile par exemple et que je
vous demande d'aller vous laver les
mains juste sous un filet d'eau
ça marche pas bien franche pas bien le
l'huile elle va rester sur vos mains
elle va pas du tout partira au filet
d'eau et ça quelque part c'est un peu
normal je vous ai expliqué tout à
l'heure l'eau et l'huile elle s'aime pas
du tout elles n'ont pas du tout envie de
cohabiter donc a aucune chance que
l'huile qui est tranquillement accroché
sur vos mains accepte de partir dans le
filet d'eau donc si vous l'avez vos
mains pleines d'huile avec juste de
l'eau ça marchera pas c'est pour ça
qu'on utilise du savon est en fait le
savon sa propriété c'est que il réduit
la tension entre l'huile et l'eau il et
les rend plus compatibles il fait en
sorte que l acceptent de se parler et et
du fait qu'on utilise le savon pour se
laver les mains fait que l'huile
acceptent de quitter nos mains pour
partir dans le filet d'eau donc donc le
liquide vaisselle ou le savon c'est un
espèce d'ambassadeurs entre l'huile et
l'eau pour pour les rendre plus
compatibles alors qu'est ce qui se passe
quand je m'amuse ajouté du liquide
vaisselle dans mon pastis allongée on a
dit que la raison fondamentale pour
laquelle le pastis ce trouble est et
parce que l'huile se retrouver au milieu
de l'eau que ça lui allait pas du tout
le fait d'ajouter le produit vaisselle
fait que finalement l'huile essentielle
elle est pas si malheureuse que ça et du
coup elle accepte de retourner se
disperser dans liquide dont toutes les
gouttelettes d'huile qui s'était qui
étaient apparues et qui avait créé le
phénomène de diffusion
en fait elles sont elles sont ce des
fonds et les molécules repart
tranquillement partout dans le vert et
donc le pastis redevient transparent et
imbuvable accessoirement alors vous vous
demandez peut-être pourquoi il ya des
gens qui sont amusés à étudier ces
phénomènes là le dire foot du pastis du
liquide vaisselle dans le pastis c'est
quoi l'intérêt en fait détrompez-vous
parce que ce qui se passe dans ces
phénomènes là c'est quelque chose de
très intéressant que des scientifiques
tout ce qui a plus sérieux se sont
amusés à étudier et donc c'est quelque
chose qui est connu dans la littérature
scientifique sous le terme d'effets
ouzou alors en fait mais on parle pas du
pastis on parle de l'ouzom et le
mécanisme est le même
et si vous amuser à taper ouzou effect
un moteur de recherche de publications
scientifiques vous allez voir des trucs
qui sortent je vous en ai mis quelques
unes ici est en fait les scientifiques
sont absolument fasciné par ce phénomène
parce qu'il permet de faire ce qu'on
appelle des micros émulsion des nano
émulsion c'est à dire que ce qui se
passe quand j'allonge bon pastis ségou
d'huile microscopiques et ça ça
intéresse beaucoup les scientifiques
parce que ça peut avoir un certain
nombre d'applications est une des
applications qui est beaucoup regardé
c'est pour faire de la délivrance de
médicaments je crois j'ai mis une des
publications là qui en parle
l'utilisation de la nano précipitations
de toulouse dans les faits ouzou pour
faire de la délivrance de médicaments
parce que ça permet de créer des
structures qu'on n'arriverait pas à
créer autrement donc à des scientifiques
qui étudient ce phénomène qui essaie de
le répliquer pour des applications
voient la com com pour faire des
médicaments alors il ya un autre
phénomène dont je voulais vous parler
qui est pas très très loin de tout ça
parce que c'est quelque chose qui se
basent un peu sur les mêmes mécanismes
et qu'on retrouve beaucoup dans le
domaine de l'alimentation c'est la
mousse à la mousse c'est aussi un truc
fascinant qu'est ce qui est de quoi ces
faits une mousse s'est fait
principalement de deux choses en fait
c'est fait des essais fed au hockey
quand on veut faire de la mousse souvent
mais un peu liquide vaisselle mais en
proportion en fait c'est pas grand chose
par rapport à l'eau fondamentalement une
mousse et c'est de l'air et de l'eau et
c'est un peu bizarre est ce que l'os est
un liquide
ok l'air c'est un gaz et je m'amuse à
mélanger un gaz et un liquide et
j'obtiens un truc qui grosso modo se
comporte comme un solide à solide un peu
mou mais bon un solide quand même
j'obtiens un solide en mélangeant un
liquide et un gars c'est quand même
assez amusant alors quand comment ça
marche une mousse pourquoi est ce qu'on
arrive à faire des mousses pourquoi
pourquoi ces structures là existe en
fait c'est un peu pour la même raison
que ce que je vous ai raconté sur les
émulsions je vous ai dit l'huile et
l'eau ne s'aiment pas en fait l'eau et
l'air ne sommes pas non plus l'eau
déteste être en contact avec l'air pour
ça que si vous prenez si vous regardez
de lolo elle se met en en gouttes ou en
gouttelettes qui sont généralement plus
ou moins sphérique
est ce que c'est la forme qui permet à
l'eau doit avoir le moindre contact
possible avec l'air donc l'eau déteste
être en contact avec l'air et quand on
ajoute du savon du produit vaisselle
il se passe la même chose c'est-à-dire
que le savon est le produit vaisselle
réduisent un peu cette tension entre
l'eau et l'air
font que l'eau accepte de se laisser un
peu étalée partout et c'est comme ça
qu'on arrive à mettre de l'air dans de
l'eau et à créer des mousses évidemment
là dans le domaine de l'alimentation il
ya un cas qui est très connu
c'est celui des des blancs en neige
comment ça se passe alors déjà le blanc
d'oeuf là une fois de plus ce qu'est ce
que c'est fondamentalement c'est
essentiellement de l'eau je rappelle un
love c'est une cellule donc les cellules
du corps humain mais aussi de les autres
organismes sont fait majoritairement
d'eau donc en fait le blanc d'oeuf c'est
quand même fondamentalement de l'eau
sauf que dedans il ya un certain nombre
de molécules notamment des protéines qui
ont la propriété de se comporter un peu
comme mon liquide vaisselle qui ont un
peu cette fonction de rendre un peu plus
compatibles l'eau et l'air et c'est pour
ça que quand on fait monter les oeufs en
neige
on arrive au bout d'un moment à obtenir
une mousse alors si vous avez déjà fait
cet exercice vous savez que la mousse
qu'on obtient elle dépend beaucoup de la
manière dont on va battre du temps qu'on
va mettre etc
et ça c'est quelque chose que les
scientifiques aussi étudie beaucoup
il étudie beaucoup la manière dont on
obtient des mousses plus ou moins
rigides par exemple ou avec des bulles
plus ou moins petit ou plus ou moins
stable en fonction de la manière dont on
l'a fait la question de la stabilité par
exemple donc là j'ai pris de la mousse à
raser
si je laisse cette assiette ici et que
je reviens dans deux trois heures la
mousse sera probablement à leur a pas
beaucoup diminué ses new skies est
plutôt stable
si je fais la même chose avec du liquide
vaisselle et que je reviens dans dix
minutes plus tard la mousse se sera
effondré
c'est des questions sur la manière dont
on fait la mousse la mousse va être plus
ou moins stable et là c'est des choses
qui intéressent beaucoup les
scientifiques beaucoup dans le domaine
de l'agroalimentaire il ya énormément de
recherches qui est fait dans les
départements de recherche de l'industrie
agroalimentaire de l'industrie de la
bière aussi évidemment mais pas que ça
et tout ce qu'on peut apprendre sur la
manière dont fonctionnent les mousses
peut être utilisé dans d'autres domaines
à moi personnellement j'ai travaillé
dans le domaine des matériaux de
construction et notamment d'essayer
d'utiliser des mousses pour faire des
matériaux de construction
pourquoi vous savez peut-être qu'on est
dans un monde de cas un léger petit
problème avec l'énergie est en fait dans
un pays comme la france aujourd'hui à
peu près 45 % de l'énergie qu'on dépense
c'est pour les bâtiments et c'est
principalement pour les chauffer et dans
une certaine mesure aussi les climatiser
essai de l'énergie qu'on met stupidement
par la fenêtre littéralement d'ailleurs
parce que c'est l'énergie qu'on pourrait
ne pas dépenser si on avait des
bâtiments qui était très bien isolé ce
qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui est une
manière de faire des matériaux plus
isolants c'est notamment de faire des
mousses alors on peut faire des mousses
de béton des mousse de ciment et quand
on fait ça non seulement avant les
matériaux plus légers mais en plus on
les rend plus isolants et pour arriver à
faire ça il faut réellement comprendre
ce qui se passe dans le mécanisme de la
mousse et c'est dans ces situations là
que le travail des chercheurs qui
travaillent sur des domaines plutôt
agroalimentaire est plutôt sur les
matériaux se rejoignent on se retrouve
finalement à se poser les mêmes
questions
elle en conclusion il ya trois choses
que je voudrais que vous reteniez de ces
petits jeux
la première c'est que dans nos assiettes
et puis dans nos verres aussi il se
passe des phénomènes de physique et
chimie qui sont potentiellement vraiment
compliqué et qu'on comprend pas du tout
la deuxième chose c'est qu'il ya des
gens tout à fait sérieux des
scientifiques dans des laboratoires qui
passent leur temps à essayer de
comprendre ce qui se passe et quand ils
y arrivent ça peut avoir des
applications dans des domaines qui
peuvent être assez éloigné de
l'alimentation ou bien la boisson merci